And, this is a really tricky question. So,
clearly, densities don’t have to be positive
everywhere. It suffices to be non-negative
and I gave you examples where outside of
certain interval density was zero. Zero is not
positive. Zero is just non-negative. Now,
densities don’t have to be continuous. I gave
you an example of a density like this. And,
over here where the density jumped, you had
a point of discontinuity. So, continuous is
not correct. And, if you got this wrong,
no big deal. The word continuous might not
even mean much to you. But, it’s one of these
things to know about densities. Now, smaller
or equal to 1, that’s a really tricky one. And, I
would submit that’s not correct and here’s why.
Suppose you have a density that assigns
uniform probability only to values between 0
and 0.1, then the height of this density could
be 10; it’s 1 over 0.1. And, as a result, it’s
possible that densities can exceed 1. And
that is a key point that makes them different
from probabilities. Probabilities are always
smaller than or equal to 1. Densities can be larger than 1.